now Nicola Adams will embark on her
professional career tonight after taking
the amateur boxing world by storm she's
the world's first female boxing olympic
champion having won gold in her home
games at London 2012 then again at Rio
in 2016 the flyweight has said she wants
to be the first female boxer to headline
an event in Las Vegas and she joins me
now live from Manchester welcome to you
how are the nerves before the big fight
oh I'm feeling pretty good right now
confident I'm just ready to go I can't
wait to get in the ring I think if you
said to me I was boxing in five minutes
of you there all the training this is
where it all comes together but it's
quite a leap though isn't it going from
amateur to professional or not not
really it's been a lot a lot more full
of a journey though Media workouts and
the public gets to see me a little bit
my Sam I'm enjoying every minute of this
now you've got the the nickname that
they're smiling assassin is that one
that you accept do you live up to it
well my nickname is actually the lioness
oh I get the smiling assassin from yeah
a lot of people actually call me that as
well so which one do you prefer which
one's more accurate the lioness the
lioness so what can we expand my logo as
well what can we expect from the fight
later on this evening you're going to
expect and you're gonna see a really
good performance from me I've trained
hard so I know I know the tactics I know
what I need to do it's gonna be an
exciting night don't miss it I'll be
here I'll be here Nicholas I might miss
it now when did it all change for you
was it
the the first Olympics was that really
when you decided this is really what I
need to do and I'm going to climb as far
as I can in this sport yeah definitely
after the first Olympics I wanted to
become a double Olympic champion yet we
never had one and I wanted to be the
first female boxer
to hold all the tiles and I'm actually
the first female or male to be able to
do that and so for the world the
Europeans Commonwealth and the Olympics
all at the same time now in that first
Olympic gold medal you fought Marlen
Esparza and I found out a very
interesting fact today that she was well
well go ahead go ahead
I actually did a boxer and she boxed ran
can come in the semi-finals
and then I boxed renkin can in the
finals she was on the other side of the
draw to me right but but she has been on
the other side and she was a competitor
but no longer because following on from
that um became a partnership outside of
the ring yeah we did yeah would you ever
fight her though no definitely not
ago we have got a small we have got a
small rivalry going on in the household
it's gonna be the first person to have
the world title on the mantelpiece Oh
healthy healthy domestic rivalry because
she's recently turned professional as
well hasn't she yes yes yeah so
definitely you won't fight each other
but having someone a partner who's in
exactly the same sport that must provide
a lot of support for you on a day-to-day
basis yeah it does definitely it's nice
to know and I'm with someone that
understands all the struggles all the
highs and the lows and that we go
through in the spot do you train
together yes we do and who's better you
can tell me I don't know we both work
pretty hard so your titles as an amateur
world european commonwealth and olympic
what are your ambitions as a
professional oh definitely to become
multi-way world champion I'm striving
for the best and hopefully one day I can
headline a show in Vegas
that's the that's the ultimate goal and
your style as an amateur does it change
when you enter the
as a professional other things that
you're doing differently now yes there
is I'm learning to sit down on my
punches create a little bit more power
and placing my shots for accuracy more
than the amount of punches that I'll be
throwing so I'll for Less but they'll be
more accurate and placed correctly I
must say you're ever so calm and if I
was walking into a ring with someone who
is going to know ten bells outed me I'd
be a little bit nervous but there you
are smiling away as calm as a cucumber
yeah this is the this is the thing you
see I've done that all my training I've
done all the hard work I've listened to
the coaches so now I'm like I have
nothing to worry about
I've done everything possible that I can
do so I can go into the ring confident
knowing that I've listened to the
coaches not cut any corners in training
and I can go in feeling confident and
comfortable one of your heroes I know
was Muhammad Ali he used to predict the
round that it would be all over in are
you going to be able to predict will you
go that far and be as cocky as Muhammad
Ali oh alright then I'll see first round
stoppage Wow Wow you know we're gonna
hold you to it because everyone's hit
that now the very best of luck we will
be watching Nicola Adams thank you very
much for speaking to us thank you